so it was in the news that there's a 50-pound
note coming out with alan turing on it now alan
turing has been featured from time to
time on our our channel and rightly so
dave's done some fabulous videos on all the
work that he and a lot of others were doing at
bletchley park you know cracking enigma and it got
me thinking you know now that we're in the 21st
century and i've got a laptop that's much more
powerful than all the cheering bombs put together
how easy is it to break enigma like today right
so i thought let's code up and find out the first
thing i should say is they've done some really
interesting videos on the history of enigma and uh
do go and watch those right and it'll give you an
idea for sort of things they were doing to try and
break enigma back during the 40s not to trivialize
it but it's really difficult isn't it it's really
really difficult right you know this isn't
something one does by hand right not quickly um
the enigma machine is not a stupid idea right it's
well designed the only thing that we've got now is
much much more processing power and so things that
we couldn't possibly brute force back then maybe
we can start to begin to brute force now right
and that's what we're looking at today so let's
look very briefly at what the knitting machine is
and then we'll have a go at actually breaking one
and see whether it holds up if you recall it has
some lights on some letters and it has this is my
technical description has some buttons that you
press keys are they cool sometimes so you press
an a right you press an a and it goes into the
machine and it goes through something called a
plug board and the plug board will swap it so this
is the plug board here now plugs just swap certain
letters in pairs so maybe this a comes out as a an
f right or something like that then this goes into
the first rotor and so that maybe comes out as a q
or something like that so you know it sort of just
wiggles around in here and then this comes in this
comes out as maybe you know a p i'm making this up
and then this goes into the next rotor to
stick to three rotary enigmas for today hey
uh comes out as a sort of an s and then it
goes through something called a reflector so
this is getting quite complicated but this is all
mechanical right these rotors literally physically
turn around and they just have wires soldered
from one end to the other that connect up so the
reflector just bounces s goes to something else i
can't remember which led is and then it goes back
through this like this and then it comes around
through the plug board again so maybe that d
goes to i mean a's over here that was that
was a bit silly of me wasn't it um over here
for the purposes of this it's all absolutely fine
and this comes out as a zed right so in my in in
my weird botched enigma diagram the a went in and
it came out as a zed it was encrypted as a zed
now what's hard about this problem well you
can take these rotors out right each rotor has
different wiring there's usually five or eight
rotors to choose from and you can put them in
any position you like the next one is that every
time you press a letter one of the rotors rotates
and sometimes it rotates the next rotors along and
that means that this mapping this transformation
changes every time you press a character so
you press a it's not going to do the same
thing again no actually if you press a the rotor
first turns and then lights up a letter right so
it's not going to do the same again if you press
aaaa the only thing you're guaranteed due to one
of the quirks of enigma is you won't get any
a's back but you'll get a lot of random letters
back during the war they solved this by trying
to find possible rotor configurations that
definitely couldn't work or could work based
on some guest playing text so maybe they had
this idea that the first part of the message
contained the word weather report and so if
they put that in and they then they could find all
the encryptions that couldn't possibly have come
out as weather report and so on and they could
start to narrow down what their options were now
that's called a known plane text attack but during
the war if they hadn't known the plaintext they
wouldn't be able to crack enigma they didn't have
the brute force power to do it nowadays we have
pretty fast laptops right and you know beyond my
laptop other computers are even faster than that
would you believe so theoretically we could
start to try out some of these combinations
even if we didn't know any plain text what we're
going to be looking at at least to begin with is a
ciphertext text only attack that's an attack where
we've only got the cipher text we don't have any
idea what the plain text is and we want to see if
we can guess what some of these settings would be
there's a few interesting weaknesses of enigma
that make it a little bit practical to brute force
but not actually as much as you think we talk
a lot about how a letter doesn't encrypt ever
to itself and that's quite relevant for plain
text attacks known plain text because you can
then work out where plaintext definitely can't
or could be we're not doing that today so i'm
less worried about that particular property of
enigma more interesting to me is the fact that
if you get some of the settings right like you
get this rotor correct but these two wrong that
will often be better at decrypting than if you get
them all wrong right so as we start to move slowly
towards a solution we get a little hint that maybe
this ciphertext isn't quite as good as it was
and we can start measuring it so really what
we need to do is find some way of putting some
some ciphertext into an enigma machine with
some configuration and then reading the output
and saying is that a plausible sentence or not
right and preferably we'd like to do it really
really quickly because otherwise this could take a
long time so we're not going to be doing any deep
learning can't be bored with that um we're going
to use very simple statistical properties of text
to try and measure whether one sentence is better
as english than another sentence right and there's
a few of these and i've implemented all of them
because i thought well let's just test them out
right so the first one is something called index
of coincidence so let's suppose you have a cipher
text so for example oh here it is i'm just looking
at random text right so yeah okay i'm just going
to copy some random cipher text from here right
so why i can't just randomize my own soft text
i don't know but i feel more comfortable copying
it than i do just thinking up clever interesting
letters on my own said well so there's no
number files on the fact that i don't pick
as random as i think and stuff like that yeah
so you then do s e uh b h w this is some actual
cipher text that we'll be breaking later does it
honestly start with zeus as in conrad's use yeah
the reality of random yeah yeah yeah yeah um you
see all kinds of words in the random ciphertext
and they mean absolutely nothing because it hasn't
been decrypted yet uh oh g yeah well exactly
e u so let's suppose we have some type of
text like this we guess some rotor settings
and we put it through our enig machine enigma
machine and that will decrypt it right now it
will probably decrypt it incorrectly but where
we accidentally stumble upon the right plugs
or we stumble upon the right rotor configuration
even for a briefly we'll find that this decryption
is slightly better than completely random right
because actually mostly this is completely random
right yes we have this stipulation that letters
can't turn into themselves but generally speaking
it looks completely random so this is what we get
out so h f my writing is bad today v v f l i n
g now the interesting thing about this is i mean
it's complete nonsense right let's let's i'm not
cracking any words on this but i do recognize ing
now ing is a fairly common trigram or set of three
characters in the english language right now that
doesn't necessarily mean this is correct but it's
slightly more english should we say than this one
right so if we were measuring some amount of how
english is this sentence how you know then it's
a little bit closer than this so maybe one of our
rotors is in the right position and the others
are wrong right or our rotor's in the correct
position but our plugs are wrong or something
like this right and the idea is that we slowly
go through different configurations of our enigma
machine i say slowly as fast as we can right and
we measure statistical properties of these
output sentences to find the ones that clo
most closely resemble correct decrypted text
right and we can do this without looking at them
we don't have to look at them and say well
that's a real word we just measure statistical
properties so what are some of these statistical
properties well the first one is called the index
of coincidence or i o c this is the probability
that when you pick two letters at random
they'll be the same so for example if we randomly
pick p and then we randomly pick p that's versus
the same if we pick p and then l they're not the
same you know we won't write the formula the form
is not that complicated so but what you have to
do is go through and count count every single
character and how many of each one there are you
produce a histogram and then you can calculate
the index of coincidence based on this now
for random text that is text that's been put
through the machine are not decrypted the index of
coincidence is usually something like 0.038 right
which is basically everything's evenly distributed
there's nothing interesting going on there at all
but for decrypted english text we usually
get a higher index of questions about 0.067
and i think it's something like 0.072 for german
text one way of looking at it is it measures the
the the fact that some characters have more higher
probabilities than others if everything's equally
likely you get something like this if some
characters are quite common and so they tend
to come up in pairs it starts to look a little
bit higher right it never goes higher than this
so well not really what we can do is we can work
through our rotors different rotors different
positions different settings and we can calculate
our index of coincidence and we take the best
scoring texts right so where our output has
a higher index equations we think maybe we've
got the rotor settings correct right and that's
basically how it works there's been a number file
right where they actually got to use the enigma
machine and i'm super jealous they talked about
the number of different combinations so it's all
very well saying okay we'll just go through all
the rotor settings and work out you know what
the best one is right maybe if i have you know
a super super super computer um but actually
enigma has a nifty weakness in this sense right
which is that if you get some of the settings
correct this will improve right if i get the voter
positions correct even though the rotors are in
slightly wrong position the result will be better
than if i've got the wrong rotors in place right
if i get one of the plug board settings right
the results would be better than if i got none of
the plug board settings right because basically
fewer characters will be incorrect right
subtly so you've got three out of let's say
five rotors or eight rotors so that's physically
the three that happen to be in the machine at
the time yeah and you've got their different
positions right so if for today we just talk
about five rotors just because i've always been
sitting here a little bit longer then we've got 60
possible positions one we've got to choose three
out of five and then they can all go in any slot
you don't tend to have the same motor twice right
because i mean they didn't have those duplicates
of rotors yeah one set of them yeah yeah yeah yeah
um so we've got that then for each of these we
have a start position from from uh 1 to 26 which
is you know what letter is showing on the top
right basically how how rotated it is so you've
got the start position or the indicator setting
so there's you know times let's say 26 of those
times by three of the different motors right then
you've got the ring setting now the ring setting
is essentially rotating the internals of the
rotor right now actually if you if we ignore the
notch for a minute which i'll talk about if you
rotate the ring and you rotate the the um actual
whole rotor they kind of cancel each other out so
it's about the notch position really the notch is
when the rotor turns it turns the next one along
and so the combination of your start position and
your ring setting will mean where your notch is
and then when it turns around so you've got the
ring settings right which is going to be 26 x
3 again then we've got the plug board which
as you know swaps random characters and that's
got something like 10 different pairs out
of 13 possible pairs that's 150 trillion
i think different combinations that's you know
out of reach of my laptop um certainly when i'm
doing all these decryptions as well and we're
multiplied by all these things right the number
file goes into much better detail on this we're
looking at five today because uh again i don't
want to be here all day it does get harder to
solve and we'll talk about that so this is a
lot of combinations it's too many combinations
for me to go through even with this nice little
industrial coincidence thing right even though
when i get this exactly right i will just get
the plain text out and it will have a very nice
illness coincidence and i might be able to find it
so what do we do well the weakness of enigma is
that if we get some of these things right even if
the others are wrong we get a little bit closer
to the answer usually so for example if you get
the correct three rotors in the correct positions
and you get their start positions roughly correct
if your ring settings are wrong all that'll do
is mess around with the notches so you'll get
bits of your plain text correct and then bits
of cipher text and then bits of plain text and
you get these kind of pockets of valid characters
coming out of into the into the decryption it will
still score better on ioc or any other metric
so that's what we're going to do and this is
the same with the plugs if we get the rotors and
the start positions and the ring settings correct
then we can start to guess plugs and
generally speaking if we guess one correctly
the output would better and we can then move
towards a solution there's a lot of possible
variations but the fact that we can deal with some
of them at a time makes this practical right if we
had to brute force through all the different
variations it wouldn't be possible that's the
idea so i've written some code to do this um if
you want to have a go i'll make my code available
but also there's a really good online tool called
crypto which lets you do this in a visual way
uh we'll put a link to that in the description
but i've written some pretty simple code here i
implemented an enigma machine because it was fun
um and then i implemented a number of different
fitness functions right which is how good is our
decryption in index of questions is one right
i also um maybe we can talk about some others
another time so you were kind enough to send me
some ciphertext i don't know what it is and it's
been encrypted by some enigma configuration with
i think five plugs the first thing i do is i go
through all the different rotor configurations
and i find the one that has the highest index of
coincidence score when it decrypts that message
so this is of five different rotors each one tried
in each position and at each starting position
so that's 26 for each one so that's quite a few
combinations about 17 000 but 17 000 for a laptop
in 2021 not such a big deal right takes somewhere
around 10 seconds or something like that right so
you can see what it's doing now is it's stepping
through the different rotors so one two three one
two four one two five and we've done about 10 or
15 configurations already and for each of these
it's going through all the different starting
positions but we're not looking at ring settings
and we're not looking at plug board because that
will just multiply this astronomically by the
number of things we have to do so we're already on
rota 3 in the left-hand side we're keeping going
this same thing works exactly the same for eight
rotors it doesn't really change anything it just
takes slightly longer and i'm a bit lazy so i
have actually coded up the other motors as well
um interestingly enough some of the later
rotors have two notches on right which is
not it doesn't make any difference in terms of
the cracking because um so that just means it
turns the next one twice as well yeah yeah twice
often yep um only really affects the first two
rotors the last one doesn't ever really turn that
often and it doesn't have any other motor to turn
so here what we've got is we've got a list of
the top performing rotor configurations so 2
5 3 is the best performing rotor configuration
with start positions of 21 3 and 25
i'm using zero indexing right which is not how
you would normally do it in enigma but it was
easier for my array indexing to do this right
and that has an index of coincidence of 0.043
which is a lot higher than 3 8. i say it's a
lot higher it's a little bit higher good enough
so that suggests to me i mean we actually i listed
the top 10 here because sometimes you might not
get the one on the top one you might get the next
rotor configuration or something like this it's
worth maybe if you were trying to really actually
pay attention to this what you would do is maybe
start doing further attacks on the top three
rotor configurations just to keep your options
open so we're gonna fix at two five and three
because you know it saves time right um so given
rotors two five three from left to
right and their starting positions
what we now can do is we can start to brute
force through the ring settings so we can
find the best possible ring settings right now
this is almost instant because there's now only
600 or so of those right um we don't need to
try the left-hand rotor because it doesn't
really rotate and so we do that and it's already
happened and the best ring positions were 0 3 23
right now the zero we ignore because it's not
the ring possessing remember affects where the
notch is and the left rotor doesn't turn anything
over so it doesn't have any effect so given that
this is the ciphertext we've got out this was
our original ciphertext and this is our slightly
better ciphertext now it still looks like total
nonsense right but it has a much higher index of
coincidence score than the original which means
in some sense it's less random so if you look you
might start to see groups of letters that might be
a real word they might not i don't know right but
some of the real letters are going to come out
here we might not be able to see what they are
so given this we can finally start addressing this
really problematic plug board situation remember
there's far too many plug ball combinations to
realistically just try them all but again we have
this wonderful benefit that if we get one of the
plugs correct the result will probably be better
than if we got none of them right so what we do
is we go through each of the first 300 and so
different possible plugs just one at a
time and we see which the best one is
right and then we fix it and we do the next for
the next one and that's two plugs and then we do
for next to the next one and that's three plugs
right and so on and if we do that we very quickly
come up with a few sets of plugs and our
ciphertext is starting to look a lot better right
so this is our ciphertext here the first letter
is a nonsense but then is reposed to consider
the quest que consider the quest can machines
think ah see now i'm starting to guess what
this might be oh i see what you've done here this
is the alan turing paper so some of the letters
are wrong right so it should be i propose to
consider and it's j brapos to consider right
and we're nearly there but that's because when
we optimized the motor configuration we fixed
the rings at zero zero zero so it was never going
to find the exact correct thing so essentially the
turnover is slightly wrong everything's slightly
wrong but it's still pretty good now if we go
back to our original question as to how secure
is enigma the answer is not very secure right
and the reason is not because it's trivial to
break right this took me a little bit of effort
and for short messages where these fitness
functions start to break down because you don't
have enough information they're actually actually
very robust right for a 50 character message
very very difficult to break using something like
an index of coincidence because even if some of
the letters start to appear right there's not very
many of them the index is just noise in the war
they limited or they they attempted to limit
messages to something like 200 250 characters
for this reason because index of coincidence was
already known right and there's now more powerful
metrics like trigram scores and quadrants which
i've also implemented which often work better
particularly for the plug board and so if
you have a short message you don't get very
much information on the different frequencies of
different groups of letters and so there's really
no way to know what's going on at all right and
you get very lucky or you don't and most likely
you don't right the other issue is of course the
number of plugs i've only done five plugs here so
i've cheated a bit right for most german messages
were sent using 10 plugs you're going to need 1200
to 1500 characters before fitness functions are
going to start to give you something right if you
know what the playing text might be this becomes
much much easier right because if you can fix
these characters have to be exactly this your
fitness function is much less noisy right i know
actually i've implemented that as well and it just
starts breaking it no no like nobody's business
right so it is crackable right if you know if you
can guess what plaintext is and of course modern
cryptography assumes you know what the plain
text is right at least for some of the message
for example whenever you send an http message
to a web server the beginning bit always says
http get or something similar right but there's a
very known structure to these things you can start
to guess what they would be we can't assume that
you wouldn't know what any of the plaintext was
but even if we don't you can see that these index
of coincidence and trigram scores and things can
start to tease out some information um so going
back to the beginning enigma is actually harder
to crack than i thought right people always talk
about how hard it was to crack during the war and
that's absolutely fine but you just kind of assume
that now it's 2021 laptops should be able to just
click go for all the settings find yourself
the ciphertext doesn't really work that way
right you have to try and stumble your
way towards it and often it doesn't work
and there's noise in the output and so you have
to try and work out whether what you're seeing is
actually improvement or not and so on which
i think is quite interesting modern ciphers
don't have this problem if you have a 128 bit as
key you can't brute force the first bit because
different like the zero or one won't give you any
better or worse playing text right it will just be
nonsense each time and that's true of any amount
so you can't do like the first half of the key
and then the second half of the key which is kind
of what we're doing here so modern ciphers don't
have this problem and so on we can't do a lot of
interesting things with this image after just one
set of convolutions but we're getting there so
this one is starting to be transformed some of
them are noisier than others paint associated with
it showing which was the proper setting with a at
the top an a against the dot of paint
AUTOCAPS MANUALLY PUBLISHED